για όλα τα μαθήματα α δημοτικού γυμνασίου καιλικίου η τεχνική δουλεύει μέσα αποπρόγραμμα της ευρώπης
και ζητήσαμε αυτό πρώτα μείωση της περιτής ήλης από όλουσε όλα τα μαθηματα και το
δεύτερο μετά τροπί αυτό που ζητάμε σε εκανότητης και δεξιότητες αντί να τους ρωτάμε που
εγεννήθηκε νοτάδε και πότε που μπορεί να το βρίσε όλες τις βάσεις δεδομένω ηλεκτρονικά ρωτήστετους
πράγματα που θα τους κάνουν να σκέφτουνται καλύτερα αυτό που θέλει και η αγορά εργασίας
επιτρέψετε μο να τόπο αυτό δεν θα σου πει κανένας για να παρισδουλειά που γεννήθηκε
νοτάδε και πιος αλλά θα σε βάλει να παρουσιάσεις των εαυτός σου να μπορέσεις να
κάμεις μια παρουσία συνεσ τις τους στόχους σου κριτική σκέψεη αυτά τα χαρακτηριστικά καιτε εκανώντης
που πρέπει να καλιεργούμε δηλαδή συνπως έχουμε την πρώτη δουλειά τη μειωμένη ίδιήλητην έχουμε και
δουλεύουμε και εφέ τος σε δεύτερη φάση περαιτερομείωση και διασύνδεση με την πληροφορική της νέεις
τεχνολογήες και τενα γορα ενεργήτω σαυση τον που για χρόνια γινότα βόλευε κάποια σκαταστάσεις δγιατί
δεν κάναμε το βήμα να αλλάξει κάτι δεν θέρουσαμε περικτύλη γιατί έτσι έμαθαν και εκπαιδευτική
μας μπορείτε να μου κάνεται και μια πιος κλινηνα ερώτηση αφου ήμου στο σύστημα γιατί
δεν το κάναμεαυτό ποείναι δια συμδεδεμένω μετούτων που μλέβε τώρα και θέλω να απάντησω γιατί
είναι δύσκονα ανδένεισε εκπαιδευτικώς να καταλάβεις αυτό που λέμε μετα αναλυτικά προγράμματα ευτυχώς η κυβέρνηση
το έχει αντιληφθεί και το έχει περιλάβεις στο πρόγραμμα διακυβέρνησης ότι είναι σημαντικό να βελτιώσουμε
να λύσουμε το θέμα μεταναλυτικά προγράμματα για χρόνια η πολύλη σημαν ι πολλέεις ώρες δη
δασκαλίας διορισμί στην εκπαίδευση και ξανά το ίδιον ένας άριστος μαθητής όπως είπα πριν είναι
αυτός που μπορεί να ποστηθίση από μνημονεύση αυτό δε σημαίνει ότι μπορώ να σεβαστώ και
τη διαφορετικότητα μέσα στην τάξεη δεν προλαββα